tomorrow the house will vote to repeal
Obamacare so if you're thinking about
getting a life-threatening illness it
could bankrupt you and your family
today's the day Republicans need 216
votes and only have a margin of error of
21 votes which is much smaller than 3
million vote margin of error they needed
to win the election that is why Steve
Ben and sent his assistant
thrice-married Atlantic City casino
magnate next pizzahut spokesman Donald
Trump to convince Republicans to take
health insurance away from millions of
people also the Gulf and time permitting
avoids third wife now back in Mordor DC
House speaker and sociopath Mickey Mouse
Club member Paul Ryan has been leading
the effort and enticing amendments to
the new health bill to attract more
Republican votes because the thought of
kicking 14 million people off their
health insurance just isn't doing it for
him anymore you guys so comedians what
amendments can they add to the American
Health Care Act to make it more
attractive to Republicans all right
health care is free to anyone who agrees
to be a slave okay all right we're gonna
cost us Eugene if you are diagnosed with
an STD Paul Ryan pushes you out a window
some young boys in an airport restroom
all right